si vous vous êtes promenés en gaspésie
cet été vous avez peut-être entendu
parler de l'abondance des retours de
saumon dans certaines rivières
mais attention les chercheurs nous met
en garde pour déterminer une tendance il
faut étudier le phénomène sur de longues
périodes et dans le cas du saumon de
l'atlantique et retour en rivière sont
nettement en déclin depuis 50 ans
il
ces saumons de l'atlantique sont de
retour dans leurs rivières après deux
années en mer partout en amérique du
nord
de moins en moins de saumons remontent
les rivières pour se reproduire
la fédération du saumon atlantique qui
est de publier sa toute dernière étude
sur le sujet seulement 104 1000 grands
saumons sont retournés dans les rivières
nord-américain en 2019
c'est une des trois pires années en 50
ans de suivi
ce graphique est éloquent illustre
l'abondance de grands saumons depuis
1970 et la chute est vertigineuse
[Musique]
début des années 70 les pêches
commerciales pratiquées au large du
groenland ont déjà fait leurs ravages
sur le stock américain de saumon face à
ce déclin le canada interdira
graduellement la pêche commerciale au
large de ses côtes
entre 1984 et 2000 mais ce ne sera pas
suffisant
l'effort canadien combinée à la
réduction de la flottille internationale
n'empêchera pas le saumon de poursuivre
sa descente
[Musique]
c'est que les menaces ne sont pas qu'en
mer à cette époque la déforestation et
l'agriculture aux abords des rivières
favorisons le réchauffement de l'eau de
même que l'apport de polluants ou
rivières les barrages hydro électriques
seront aussi au nombre des coupables au
québec tout comme dans les maritimes et
aux états unis
beaucoup de barrages couperont l'accès
des géniteurs à leur site de frais
aujourd'hui n'est pas ça saumon de même
que les aménagements faits en rivière
portent fruit
on a considérablement augmenté la
production de ce mono qui partent chaque
année vers le groenland pour s'alimenter
pourtant malgré tous ses efforts
l'espèce continuent de croupir dans les
bas-fonds le nombre de saumons qui
retourne à rivière reste en dessous du
seuil requis pour assurer la survie de
l'espèce à long terme
les scientifiques sont d'avis qu'il faut
maintenant chercher en mer les causes du
problème
[Musique]
l'hécatombe surviendrait au cours des
deux années que dure le voyage du saumon
vers le groenland le saumon subiraient
les bouleversements du climat que
connaît l'article
la fonte des glaces perturberait la
chaîne alimentaire
elle diminuerait par exemple la qualité
énergétique du cas blanc une des proies
favorites du saumon
[Musique]
à ces menaces il faut enfin ajouter ces
immenses cages flottantes l'élevage du
saumon est reconnue pour transmettre des
parasites et des maladies ou saumon
sauvage
les menaces qui jalonnent le parcours du
saumon restent nombreuses
pour cette raison des accords
internationaux se multiplient
jamais on a capturé si peu de saumon que
ce soit par la pêche commerciale ou
sportives
au québec la capture de saumon par la
pêche sportive reste autorisée les
seulement sur les rivières qui
atteignent un nombre suffisant de
géniteurs à ces endroits
rappelons que de plus en plus de
pêcheurs pratiquent désormais la remise
à l'eau volontaire de leur sommet